how's it going brother this is backpack
today we're gonna play whack your games
do you have some rage that needs to go
out take a [ __ ] goddamn it and what am I
supposed to do about it
I'm just kidding we're gonna play some
wack your games it says here the best
games to unleash your rage we did whack
your ex so we have four others to do
let's start with whack your ballers this
flower let's give him a flower in the
face Oh God what are you doing that's
that's no whacking that's murder evering
this is not why why don't you close it
he's still moving
he's still moving there we go what the
[ __ ] have a we got on our self into
Bruce the Gulf that can't be now okay
water bottle nice ass are you thirsty
you thirsty ho Oh God drink it [ __ ] he
likes it so much you can stop now buddy
any time now free charlatan ruler oh now
we can finally watch porn okay oh stop
who would've thought there was so many
ways to murder your boss so I can click
on his pen oh my god oh one more lamb oh
I find the mattress I never been so
happy about murdering people this is
great I win it's wack Yocum Porter
I hope my computer doesn't mind me
playing this game I had a chainsaw in
there with E ooh
oh well that's convenient yeah what what
this game is so weird goldfish or that's
either a goldfish or or a dumpling
no dumpling I can never hurt you now
that wouldn't really happen because he's
not plugged into a power cord extender
what I've did I know science shut up
well I'm glad we found love and then I
threw my computer in the sculpture and
that's when we knew we were in love
what the hell am i doing am i calling an
airstrike on my laptop don't you hold
hall up haha it's in that a little
extreme okay that bad it's pretty
impressive I gotta say that at least I
would fall in love in myself okay no
good thing she covered her eyes no what
are you doing what do you do
oh is that I thought he took a [ __ ] you
haven't lit it anyway you idiot guess
that doesn't matter
whack the thief so I can fab got it
screwdriver must be one right bass what
is this the hell do I have rabies or
some [ __ ]
oh god I have rabies
oil yeah drink this on with your penis
oh my god all right bad meat um bad well
[ __ ]
what is in the what's in the box oh all
right kid he's dead
you did it we did a press so proud final
one is wacky old teacher
Scizor hey what the [ __ ] oh my god
Nicolas Cage be sent to the prison sad
oh my god stop please
thermos ah [ __ ] oh he's like concerned
what's it what no it's so nice I feel I
don't I'm he's ball one more come on
where is it not a chair of course oh
come on oh [ __ ] oh alright don't whack
anyone violence doesn't solve anything
but video game debts everyone's had fun
playing with you today I think like you
know watching hit the sky come birthday
thank you boys for watching stay awesome
[Music]